sziasztok a következő vendégeim csilla
és brigitta lesz velük a digitális
biztonság témát jártuk körbe
programozóként az volt a tévhitem
magamról hogy én már felkészült vagyok
én ebbe a világba nőttem fel és tudok
mindent valójában alig tudok valamit
mert a digitális biztonság nem technikai
kérdés feltétlenül hanem ahogyan
beszéltünk is róla kapcsolati kérdés
beszélgettünk a közösségi
médiahasználatról az eszközhasználatról
beszéltünk a jogi viszonyokról a
különböző aspektusairól a közösségi
médiának és a a a különböző problémákról
a veszélyekről és megoldásokról számomra
nagyon inspiratív volt iratkozzatok fel
a csatornára és tartsatok velünk jövő
kedden
[Zene]